i've gotten a lot of comments this
season to watch mucho coutensei
and i finally got around to catching up
an episode before the season finishes
though which is
which is pretty sad it's not raining
yes it ends
and it's pretty great it's been a while
since i've watched an isekai other than
of course re-zero which has had a second
season airing in parts over the last
year or so
and mushoka tensei really did not
disappoint if anything i think that it
exceeded any and all expectations i had
and it's probably now one of my actual
favorite isekai anime for a number of
reasons
while it plays on many of the typical
isekai tropes of course
it brings in a lot of new traits that
keep it fresh
the main character is pervy in a pretty
funny way
each character has their own flaws and
parts of themselves to improve
but most of all the thing i enjoy most
is the way that mushog
tensei creates a conflict between the
main character's real self
the one from before they were
transported to this fantasy world
and their new self the way that it isn't
really a fresh start for him
but instead simply new circumstances
that allow him to overcome his previous
trauma
and hopefully become the best version of
himself that he can be
so join me today as i talk about mushoku
tensei and the isekai genre
and why it's so enjoyable also 95
of my viewers this month aren't subbed
yet so i mean if you could hit that
button
that'd be pretty sick let's go
in mushokutensei our main character
starts off as a 30-something-year-old
guy but no ordinary guy
he's actually a hikikomori which is a
term used in japan for
people who totally avoid any kind of
social contact
and while this could just be something
that the person willingly decides to do
a lot of hikikomori in japan becomes so
out of some kind of previous trauma or
anxiety that makes social contact very
difficult
if you haven't watched welcome to the
nhk it's not just a great anime but very
educational on the kind of life hiki
gomoris live
and the challenges surrounding it but
anyway
our main character is a hikikomori out
of a previous trauma which i won't
really detail just to keep things
generally spoiler free
but he's also kind of a degenerate on
top of that
and through a series of events he gets
hit by a truck and then transported to a
whole new fantasy world
or rather reincarnated is a better word
as a newborn child named rudius
and we see rudius grow up with the mind
of a full-grown man
inside the body of a child leading him
to be able to learn languages
and arithmetic and magic yes magic
rather quickly he's a prodigy and so we
follow him as he grows up and you know
makes a whole new life in this new world
one that is certainly far better than
the one he had before
and that's where my synopsis ends and
the analysis begins
i'll begin with my favorite part about
mushoko tensei which is the
contrast between rudius's former self
and current self
this is certainly the most unique part
about mushog tensei to me
since most isekai simply keep the main
character the same
and even if they change the character's
appearance a little bit
to begin them completely anew with a new
life as a baby
is really fresh and as he grows up
only physically i guess you see how
people look down on children
and hide things from them from an
outside perspective
from rudius's eyes rydia sees all of
this
as he grows up and it honestly feels
like the most realistic isekai i've ever
watched
which is of course an oxymoron to say
that nisekai which is inherently a
fantasy world
is realistic but even though magic and
things like that exist
i feel like every single problem we see
rudius deal with or the people around
him
is relatable adultery manipulation
bullying needing money for college
racism it's
all of humanity's real problems mixed
into a fantasy world
it's not overly fantastical or
unbelievable
and this kind of down to earth
atmosphere is assisted by you you know
seeing rudius grow up witnessing a life
inside this flawed world instead of just
throwing in a character at a random
point
and speaking of radius we also see how
he must finally overcome the issues from
his past
in this new world his inability to go
outside or
his fear rather his troubles with even
the most
simple socializing with new people it's
not something he can solve with magic or
by being a little boy genius so it's all
just very intriguing
with everything he gains a new body new
skills as a prodigy he still can't
overcome
certain things that he had before and
that's what he has to deal with
but rudius is also just a really good
guy and he has this
profound impact on many of the people he
meets
not just because he's like decades older
than any of them
mentally including his own parents but
because his experience in the real world
our world has taught him things that are
foreign and good for this new place he's
in
and as an added plus rudius is just
really funny
honestly he's pretty perverted as a 30
plus year old degenerate dude
so he gets up to some pretty hilarious
antics as he uses his status as a kid to
kind of brush it off
he's also got the same voice actor i'm
pretty sure as gintogi from gintama
which might explain why the voice actors
delivery is just so on point throughout
the show
and if you watched my ecchi video a
couple days ago mushoka tensei actually
follows what i was saying about modern
day edgy shows
how tying echi into a comedy or other
bigger genre like fantasy is the new
norm
instead of just etchy alone i don't
really know how that relates to the
topic at hand i thought i just thought
it was a cool connection
watch my other video subscribe
and of course the action and isekai part
of mushoka tensei
as a whole is also great of course
that's kind of a given
the animation has certain weak points
but it also has
really really strong points during
action sequences or
important scenes that quite excellently
encapture the beauty
and fantastical nature of magic in this
isekai world
we see beast people and demons and kings
and queens
everything you would hope for plus a
little bit of life lessons from the man
child rudius
i mean this guy is single-handedly
stopping like divorce
racism and political meltdown all at
once
while also trying to get with these like
fantasy girls it's i mean it's the best
of both worlds really
and he's like 12. so
yeah i really don't know how he's doing
it
but long story short watch michoaca
tensei
it's at episode 10 out of 11 right now
and i really recommend it it
grabs me from the start one of the only
shows this season to really do it
and it's just full of great characters
writing humor and isekai at its best
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you